well at pmq today
um kissed armor got a bit of a battering
for rowing back on his pledge to scrap
tuition fees are you comfortable with
that
I mean I I don't think that was the pmqs
I watched there were some very robust
exchanges particularly on on house
building uh that I think uh clearly the
Prime Minister seems to be on
exceptionally Shaky Ground on you know
kids made his case as he has recently
with his five missions and you know I
think we're on very comfortable
territory in terms of the the respective
Visions being sailed for the country
I just want to go through uh what kissed
armor said when he was running to be
labor leader this is to Andrew Neal he
said we remain committed to scrapping
tuition fees they're all pledges so the
answer to that question is yes and then
he was asked so University institution
fees being scrapped will be in a storm
in Manifesto and he said yes
you know as you know Sophie that took
place in what the spring 2019 since then
we've had you know two years of a global
pandemic we've had a war on the
continent of Europe we've had the Tories
crash the economy so the equation is
slightly different here is committed
have you seen through our missions to
remove the barriers to opportunity and
funding and education is one of them
we're very very clear that the system is
unfair and needs to be changed but we
will make and you know as you know we're
we're making those preparations ahead of
a general election we will make a very
strong offer about making a much fairer
system than we have at the moment and
one that crucially balances that need
with the nation's finances I think
that's what the public would expect a
responsible labor parties to do and
that's what kirstan was offering
that it was made a few years ago and the
world's changed since then as you say
but the problem is the world could
change again right how do we know that
what you guys are saying now is gonna
actually happen if later get elected
there's a trust issue
you know what you'll get from us is a
fully costed well set out Manifesto when
the election you know is is on its way
so you know of course there can be
changes even within an election campaign
but in that moment you will you'll have
a very clear sense of what we want to do
for this country I think that's the
responsible way to do it you know we
know that people want to see from labor
not a laundry list of of all the things
that we want to do for the country of
course there are lots of things we tried
that election in 2019 and and the public
were very clear about how they felt
about that instead what we'll have is a
clear fully costed affordable impactful
and Progressive Manifesto that will
change Britain for the better ending the
sticking past plaster politics we've
seen of recent years but real change in
the country to proper Mission and driven
based ways cutting crime improving
public services and creating better
opportunities that's what the public
will get from us and they'll be able to
make that judgment based on that
all right let's talk about the local
elections uh shall we because things are
really hotting up in that race and
Kirsten told me on Sunday that the
conservative should be making gains in
these sets of local elections now I've
heard of expectation management that's
not really realistic is it
I mean how could it be anything else
Sophie you know the let's read back to
when the equivalent elections were last
for which was May 2019 after that
results were so bad for the conservative
party that shortly after Theresa May
resigned we can't honestly be saying
that Rishi sunax not going to do better
and indeed might even do worse as the
Tories are saying than that will what
would that say about this uh The sunak
Surge we've been hearing about so you
know if Richie really is the answer and
despite being you know second choice of
Tory MPS second choice of Tory members
you know if he really is the right man
to leave this country will surely he'll
be making significant progress on where
Theresa May finish
see you next Serge I'm not sure if I've
heard that one before
um also the whole thing is though that
the projections that we're looking at
are because the conservatives are in a
position where they should lose seats
because you just have to look at the
polls and you know labor clawing their
way back from one of your worst ever
election defeats I mean that's where we
are not to mention the fact that they're
also defending the most number of
councils and Council seats as well let's
get real they're not going to be making
gains
well as I say if if they're not making
gains what does that say about where
they are it says that where Teresa may
finished which is you know considered I
certainly think Boris Johnson and his
supporters would say a real nadir for
the conservative party if they're doing
worse than that then that I think has
real questions about where they are I
mean obviously we're of course focusing
on on our campaign we fought a really
positive one around the cost of living
around improving public services so
we're hoping that that our candidates
are going to do really well
what would be a good night for labor
there what are you hoping for
well I mean you know we we are really
optimistic we're looking to gain seats I
think the thing for me is particularly
the wear rather than the Watts you know
if we're going to read this with with an
eye on on the next general election
which of course naturally we're going to
we're all going to be doing that then we
will be looking at the places that we
need to do well in in order to uh win
power and win the next general election
so we'll be looking to see if we've
gained seats in places like that you
know I look out the window and about 30
meters away so the red walls of course
will be looking at places like
brockstone gedling and Beyond and
Nottingham shooting to Derbyshire so
we'll be looking at those and and hoping
we're showing that we're making the
impact there that we want to be doing I
mean that's the point isn't it if you
are going to be using these local
elections to map over across to the
general election you need to be doing
more than pick up a few seats if you're
going to seriously show that you're a
government in Waiting you need to be
picking up hundreds of these
well as I said I I think the the Top
Line number can be a fooler so you know
take Nottingham for example you know we
currently have 50 out of 55 counselors I
very much hope on Friday we get up to 55
we've fought for all of those seeds and
if that happens well we'll have gained
five and the Tories will have lost two
so a change of seven seats well that
sounds like quite a lot I don't think it
would tell us any more about the general
election we already hold three uh
parliamentary seats in the city so you
know as I say I don't think it's that
Global number I think it's the where and
I think we'll soon be able to look at
those areas and to make that judgment as
to whether we're making the progress we
want to be making
just finally I've done a bit of bit of
talking
um in my time going alongside at Labor
and conservative women live Dems I
should say rather than campaigning
actually for a political party and I
have to say you do see some quite
strange things on the campaign Trail
I've seen quite a few naked people for a
start what's the weirdest thing you've
seen on The Campaign Trail yeah I'm
gonna leave aside all uh nudity uh ones
because though I think they were common
for most canvases mines of parrot
um there's a picture doing the rounds of
me in 2017 of me having a very detailed
discussion with the barrier I didn't get
the apparent support I think I got the
owners on that day
um but yeah that I think that's the most
memorable one I've had that is a good
one definitely thanks very much for
being on the program today thank you